Finlandia tiene luz verde para ingresar
a la otan tal como se esperaba Turquía
dio el visto bueno a uno solo de los
nuevos candidatos y dejó a Suecia fuera
de la ecuación
no es posible para nosotros acercarnos
positivamente a Suecia en las actuales
condiciones no tenemos los mismos
problemas con Finlandia hemos decidido
iniciar el proceso de ratificación en
nuestro parlamento la decisión fue
anunciada durante una recepción con el
presidente finlandés luego de meses
objetando el ingreso de los nórdicos
bajo la acusación de que albergaban
grupos terroristas en alusión a
militantes del proscrito partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán PK celebran
con cautela Finlandia y la otan
tengo la sensación de que la pertenencia
a la otan no está completa Sin Suecia
Tenemos tantos intereses en común al ser
vecinos y tener el área del mar Báltico
en nuestras costas
lo más importante es que tanto Finlandia
como Suecia se conviertan en miembros
plenos rápidamente No si se unen
exactamente al mismo tiempo
Mientras tanto Suecia no pierde las
esperanzas se trata de cuando Suecia se
convertirá en miembro no de Sí en
términos de nuestra seguridad nuestra
posición es mejor ahora que cuando
solicitamos el ingreso en la otan la
admisión de Finlandia no es un triunfo
completo ni siquiera para helsinki de
acuerdo con este analista
la defensa de Finlandia en términos
prácticos realmente necesita
coordinación con Suecia geográficamente
es muy significativa en los planes de
defensa de Finlandia y en los de la otan
en la Europa del Norte
ambos países solicitaron su ingreso a la
alianza atlántica a raíz del inicio de
la invasión rusa en Ucrania pero este
depende del favor unánime de los 30
países miembros